[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend so
herzlich die Atmosphäre der hohe Gast so
charmant und witzig er schwärmte von
alter Freundschaft und das auch noch auf
Deutsch man hätte fast vergessen können
wie es in den letzten Jahren zuging
zwischen den Vereinigten Königreich und
den eu-europäern wie die Tonlage
verrutschte und Porzellan zerschlagen
wurde wozu die königliche Familie
allerdings nie bei trug man darf
vermuten dass gerade die Queen die seit
frühester Jugend mit Weltpolitik und dem
Untergang des Empire befasst war er
entsetzt war über den Populismus und die
resortiments die sich mit den
brexit-kampagnen
helfen die Scherben zusammenzukehren
diese Scham Offensive ist ihrer Majestät
in Deutschland durch ausgeglückt
berichtet Andreas
am Honig stand Perschke auf dem
Wittenbergplatz kommt für einen Moment
alles zusammen das überaus höfliche
Dauer Lob ihrer majestätten
außergewöhnlich das überaus unhöfliche
Dauer schimpfen der Fotografen
brauchen sie noch mal ein Bild und die
überaus sorgfältig vorbereitete
Botschaft die König Charles vom Berliner
Ökomarkt senden will dass er selbst ein
öko ist das ist meiner einmal Honig für
den honigverkäufer falls es ein Argument
braucht für Großbritanniens Festhalten
an der Monarchie dann die
Anziehungskraft die das Königshaus auf
aktuelle deutsche Marktbesucher genauso
ausübt wie auf ehemalige deutsche
Parlaments und Bundespräsidenten auf
fast das komplette hohes hoch der
Republik die Rede die King Charles als
erster Monarch überhaupt im Bundestag
hält ist eine wieder ernährungsrede drei
Jahre nach dem brexit eng abgestimmt mit
Londons Außenminister James cleverly der
Charles durch Deutschland begleitet
noch immer bewundern wir unsere
gegenseitige Kultur noch immer sind wir
wirtschaftlich voneinander abhängig noch
immer lassen wir uns voneinander
inspirieren auch wenn jüngere
Generationen vielleicht er an die
Beatles denken oder Kraftwerk
der versöhnliche Ton den der König
anschlägt in Berlin unterscheidet sich
hörbar von der Kritik ja Genervtheit die
zuletzt aus London gemeldet wurde
Bundeskanzler Scholz wird heute keine
Zögerlichkeit mehr vorgeworfen nicht
öffentlich und vermutlich auch nicht
beim persönlichen Gespräch im
kanzlerbüro im Gegenteil
der Entschluss Deutschlands
Ukraine so große militärische
Unterstützung zu kommen zu lassen ist
überall mutig wichtig und willkommen den
Standing Ovations der deutschen
Ministerpräsidenten der Bundesregierung
des gesamten Bundestags den Innovationen
für ihre Majestät schließt sich eine
Partei mit Bauchschmerzen an es habe
schon schlechtere reden gegeben aber das
ändert ja nichts daran dass das total
skurril ist dass ich die gewählten
ParlamentarierInnen in fast sakraler
Stimmung vor einem Monarchen verbeugen
in Deutschland
ich finde das ist völlig aus der Zeit
gefallen die Monarchen ist Deutschlands
Einsatz für die Ukraine wichtig so
wichtig dass Charles die Bundeswehr
besucht das deutsch-britische
brückenbataillon so wichtig dass Charles
ukrainische Flüchtlinge besucht das
ankunftszentrum in Tegel während Camilla
ebenfalls ukrainische Flüchtlinge
besucht in einem Projekt der Berliner
Stadtmission
am Abend klettert Charles III durch
einen Straßengraben um den Deutschen in
der Uckermark noch ein bisschen näher zu
sein man kam sich entgegen heute von
beiden Seiten
es soll ja mehr Verkehr auf die Schiene
mehr Personen und mehr Güter dazu
einigte sich die Ampelkoalition ja sogar
darauf die Lkw-Maut zu erhöhen und die
Einnahmen daraus der Bahn zugute kommen
zu lassen Geld braucht sie auch dringend
89 Milliarden allein um ihr marodes
Schienennetz zu sanieren soll es darüber
hinaus auch noch modernisiert und
ausgebaut werden braucht es noch mal
deutlich mehr und nebenbei sitzt das
Unternehmen Bahn noch auf einem
Schuldenberg von knapp 30 Milliarden
heute präsentierte sie ihre Jahresbilanz
Hans-jürgen Piel berichtet
die Deutsche Bahn kommt nicht aus den
roten Zahlen noch wenn Sie heute einen
Gewinn vor Steuern von 1,3 Milliarden
Euro präsentierte unterm Strich wo sie
ein Minus von mehr als 200 Millionen ein
der Bahnchef trotzdem optimistisch im
Videos Statement den wirtschaftlichen
Erfolg verdanken wir wesentlich unserer
logistik-
den Ausbau unserer zugflotte haben wir
weiter vorangetrieben noch nie hatten
wir für unsere Fahrgäste so viele und so
moderne Züge wie heute gleichzeitig
waren die Züge aber auch noch nie so
unpünktlich jeder dritte Fernzug kam
2022 verspätet die Ursache ist bekannt
das Schienennetz verschlissen überlastet
und damit verantwortlich für die meisten
Behinderungen dazu bis zu 1200
Baustellen pro Tag jeder Einschränkung
ein Risiko für weitere Verspätungen
dieses Jahr wird kaum besser neben
hunderten kleinerer Baumaßnahmen stehen
allein elf Großbaustellen mit
monatelangen Sperrungen an Kassel Fulda
ist dabei der dickste Brocken 85 km der
wichtigsten Nord-Süd-Verbindung müssen
erneuert werden mehr als 5 Monate
Vollsperrung ab diesem Wochenende alle
Züge werden umgeleitet Fahrzeit
Verlängerung bis zu einer Stunde die
Befürchtung
die Gefahr besteht das Fahrgäste
dauerhaft abwandern im weil Sie es leid
sind dass sie eben stundenlänge
unterwegs sind oder eben vielleicht
überhaupt nicht mehr fahren können weil
keine Sitzplätze mehr vorhanden sind bei
den wenigen Zügen die noch fahren dabei
ist das nur ein Vorgeschmack im nächsten
Jahr beginnt die Generalsanierung Ausbau
und Digitalisierung der 40 wichtigsten
schienenkorridore weil Arbeiten
gebündelt werden sind die dann
voraussichtlich noch länger gesperrt
Ziel ein Hochleistungsnetz das ab 2030
Jahre lang baufrei bleiben soll
währenddessen kommt scharfe Kritik an
der Lage der Bahn vom Bundesrechnungshof
als Sanierungsfall sieht der nicht nur
das Netz sondern die DB insgesamt die
finanziellen Probleme sind immer größer
geworden das ist nahezu einfach ohne
Boden weil die Schulden wachsen und die
Einnahmen liegen schon unter dem was der
Bund jedes Jahr geben muss um die Bahn
in Betrieb zu halten es laufen jeden Tag
5 Millionen Euro Schulden neu an
da sind die im Koalitionsausschuss
gerade beschlossenen unterstützungs
Milliarden für die Bahn aus der Lkw-Maut
angesichtsrasant wachsender Verschuldung
natürlich höchst willkommen
ja nachgefragt bei unserer
wirtschaftsfachfrau Valerie Haller
Valerie was ist da schief gelaufen dass
die Bahn so stark in die finanzielle
Misere geraten ist ja vielleicht muss
man da ein Stück zurückgehen um das zu
verstehen vor 15 Jahren wollte die Bahn
an die Börse gehen um sich schick zu
machen für Investoren hat sie ein ganz
strikten Sparkurs eingeleitet weichen
und Gleise wurden abgebaut Strecken
stillgelegt ja und die fehlen heute vor
allem eben da die Verkehrsmengen so
stark gewachsen sind ein weiteres
Problem sind politische finanzielle
Fehlanreize also Instandhaltung muss die
Bahn nämlich selbst bezahlen neue Gleise
zahlt der Bund und das erklärt auch
warum Reparaturen so lange so
unattraktiv für die Bahn waren hinzu
kommen fragwürdige Investitionen in
Megaprojekte wie Stuttgart 21 ein
komplexes Firmengeflecht mit zahlreichen
Auslandsbeteiligungen wodurch sich die
Bahn schwer managen lässt und die
Vernachlässigung durch die Politik die
jahrelang stärker auf den Autoverkehr
als auf die Schiene gesetzt hat kritiker
sagen die Bahn wurde systematisch kaputt
gespart die Sanierung ist nun aber
dringlicher denn je dafür will die Bahn
auch Milliarden schwer in Vorleistung
gehen und angesichts steigender Zinsen
ist das natürlich eine teure
Angelegenheit immerhin gibt es nun eine
kräftige Finanzspritze von der Politik
auch wenn das nun Anfang sein kann
Dankeschön Valerie für die Einschätzung
hinzu kommt der Tarifkonflikt mit der
eisenbahngewerkschaft EVG die sicher mit
Verdi verbündet hat und am Montag in
einer gemeinsamen Aktion den
öffentlichen Verkehr hierzulande mehr
oder weniger lahm legte bei Verdi war
heute die dritte und letzte
Verhandlungsrunde die Arbeitgeber im
öffentlichen Dienst legten auch ein
neues Angebot vor dass die
Gewerkschaftsführung aber abschlug damit
sind die Verhandlungen bis auf weiteres
gescheitert wie es jetzt weitergeht
berichtet Nicola Albrecht
es bedarf keiner fantasievollen
Interpretation dieser Szenen um zu sagen
dass die Gewerkschaften einer Einigung
nach langem ritualisiertem Tauziehen
nicht zugestimmt haben ist ein Schock
und zwar für die Arbeitgeberseite
Innenministerin Nancy fazer und Karin
Welge Verhandlungsführerin für die
Kommunen Ringen in der nächtlichen
Pressekonferenz um konnte nonce wir
stehen noch unter dem Eindruck sehr
intensiver drei Tage wo wir hart
gerungen haben um die Chance ein
Ergebnis zu erzielen ich glaube ein
Gelächter von der rechten Seite hier
verbietet sich deutlich die Brücke die
wir geschlagen haben ist keine gewesen
die man hätte nicht begehen können
insoweit steht uns die Enttäuschung ins
Gesicht geschrieben und so sieht er aus
der Graben über den die Brücke hätte
geschlagen werden sollen Verdi und
Beamtenbund fordern 10,5% mehr Lohn
mindestens aber 500 € monatlich Laufzeit
12 Monate das Angebot von Bund und
Kommunen 8% mehr Lohn ein Mindestbetrag
von 300 € dazu eine steuerfreie
Einmalzahlung von 3000 € Laufzeit 24
Monate keine Gesprächsgrundlage für wer
die Chef Wernecke
wir mussten feststellen dass Bund und
Kommunen dass die öffentlichen
Arbeitgeber nicht in der Lage sind den
notwendigen Schritt auf die
Beschäftigten und ihre Gewerkschaften
zuzugehen um einen tatsächlichen sozial
gerechten Abschluss möglich zu machen
der insbesondere die Beschäftigten
Gruppen mit nicht so in Einkommen
ausreichend
berücksichtigt und würdigt es ist
offensichtlich die Gewerkschaften wollen
ein Zeichen der Macht setzen fühlen sich
bestärkt durch die jüngst hohe
Streikbereitschaft und 70.000 neue
Mitglieder in den letzten drei Monaten
die Kräfteverhältnisse beginnen sich
zugunsten der Arbeitnehmer zu
verschieben meinen Beobachter
wir haben eine Situation die dadurch
geprägt ist dass es einen
Arbeitskräftemangel gibt der den
Gewerkschaften einen enormen Rückenwind
ermöglicht wir haben die Situation das
drei Jahre Corona Gewerkschaften nicht
sichtbar gewesen sind und Gewerkschaften
brauchen Sichtbarkeit damit ist dass das
erste Mal dass sie wieder deutlich
machen können wie handlungs- und
durchsetzungsfähig sind und drittens
erwarten die Beschäftigten ein starken
Ausgleich der Inflation für die vorerst
gescheiterte Tarifrunde sollen nun zwei
unabhängige schlichter eine Einigung
herbeiführen für die Arbeitgeberseite
verhandelt der ehemalige sächsische
Ministerpräsident Jörg milbrath die
Gewerkschaften vertritt der ehemalige
Bremer Staatsrat Hans Henning Löhr bis
Mitte April haben Sie Zeit einen
Vorschlag auf den Tisch zu legen
gestreikt werden darf währenddessen
nicht es herrscht Friedenspflicht
[Applaus]
und es gibt noch mehr Tarif Konflikte
damit beginnen bei dir die Nachrichten
Hans ja heute gab es waren Streiks von
Ärztinnen und Ärzten an kommunalen
Kliniken in sechs Bundesländern der
Marburger Bund hatte dazu vor der
nächsten Verhandlungsrunde kommende
Woche aufgerufen zur zentralen
Kundgebung auf dem Münchner Marienplatz
kamen nach Gewerkschaftsangaben rund
4000 ärzteinnen und Ärzte die Forderung
ein Ausgleich für die Preissteigerungen
und eine Erhöhung der Gehälter um 2,5%
die Inflation in Deutschland hat sich im
März abgeschwächter Statistische
Bundesamt hat nach vorläufigen Daten
einen Anstieg von 7,4 Prozent gegenüber
dem März letzten Jahres errechnet der
russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine und
die Energiekrise wirken sich seit einem
Jahr massiv auf die Preise bei uns aus
im letzten halben Jahr lag die
Inflationsrate meist deutlich über 8%
jetzt ist sie wieder darunter
die Zahl der Straftaten in Deutschland
ist 2022 gestiegen um 11,5% im Vergleich
zum Vorjahr das geht aus der
Polizeilichen Kriminalstatistik hervor
ein Grund dafür ist etwa der Wegfall der
corona-maßnahmen
bundesinnenministerin Fräser wie es auch
auf ein entsetzliches Ausmaß
sexualisierter Gewalt an Kindern
im Vergleich zum vor Corona Jahr 2019
verzeichnet die Statistik deutlich mehr
Vergewaltigungen und sexuelle Übergriffe
auch Verstöße gegen das asyl-
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
hat sich kurz vor einer Reise nach
Peking dafür ausgesprochen das
Verhältnis zu China neu auszurichten die
EU müssen unabhängiger werden und vor
allem die wirtschaftlichen Risiken im
Verhältnis zu China minimieren forderte
sie in Brüssel es sei aber nicht im
Interesse Europas sich von China
abzukoppeln
in Israel haben sich tausende
Unterstützer der umstrittenen
Justizreform versammelt mehrere rechte
Organisationen hatten zu dem Protest
aufgerufen die Koalition von
Ministerpräsidenten Eltern Jauch will
mit der Reform den Einfluss des höchsten
Gerichts beschneiden und die
Machtposition der Regierung ausbauen
erst vor kurzem war das Vorhaben nach
massiven Protesten vorübergehend
gestoppt worden
2016 zeigten die cybertruppen des
russischen Geheimdienstes der Welt
erstmals was sie können und auch zu tun
bereit sind im US-Wahlkampf mit der
hacking-attacke auf die Demokraten und
ihre Kandidatin Clinton 2017 folgte der
Angriff auf eine ukrainische
Finanzsoftware der dazu führte dass
weltweit Firmencomputer zerstört wurden
Containerschiffe in häfenfest saßen nur
Inseln außer Betrieb gingen es entstand
ein Milliardenschaden der bislang
kostspieligste Cyberangriff in der
Wirtschaftsgeschichte das gibt eine
Vorstellung davon mit welchen Angriffen
nicht nur in der Ukraine sondern auch
hier im Westen jederzeit zu rechnen ist
hinzukommt das russische IT-Leute auch
in westlichen Unternehmen arbeiten vor
dem Krieg waren sie begehrte Mitarbeiter
die man gerne von russischen IT-Firmen
übernahm doch nicht jede normale und
harmlos wirkende russische IT-Firma ist
auch normal und harmlos dank eines
Wissens konnten westliche Medien
darunter die ZDF-Redaktion frontal tiefe
Einblicke in Moskau cyberpläne gewinnen
Ulrich Stoll und Christian Rode über die
Enthüllungen der sogenannten vulkanpfe
als Putins Truppen vor gut einem Jahr
die Ukraine überfallen und Kiew
bombardieren geht rund 1.700 km
westlichen München eine erstaunliche
Nachricht ein
es meldete sich eine Person über ein
digitales Postfach über das man anonym
Hinweise geben kann und diese Person
sagte ich möchte geheime Dokumente
Teilen über eine Firma und hinter dieser
Firma verbergen sich Geheimdienste der
Whistleblower überlässt im Journalisten
tausende geheime Papiere einer
russischen IT-Firma ihr Name NTC Vulkan
Moskau der Firmensitz von Vulkan im
Nordosten der Metropole ein
internationales Team von mehr als 50
Journalisten darunter ZDF und Spiegel
beginnt die Dokumente zu analysieren
demnach entwickelt die Firma eines
Software mit folgenden Zielen
lahmlegen von Kontrollsystemen von
Eisenbahnen Luft und Schiffstransport
und Identifizieren von Schwachstellen
kritischer Infrastruktur um sie
anzugreifen mit den vulkanfalls liegen
nun erstmals umfassende Belege dafür vor
wie der Kreml weltweit Cyberangriffe
organisiert an diesen Beispielen und
auch an vielen Vorfällen der letzten
Jahre wird deutlich dass es eine reale
Gefahr aus dem cyberraum gibt für die
kritische Infrastruktur in Deutschland
eines der vulkanprogramme soll Internet
Zugänge in besetzten Gebieten in der
Ukraine sperren und stattdessen eigene
russische Inhalte verbreiten in den
League steht wie das funktionieren soll
Anfragen von Usern werden auf gewünschte
Internet-Ressourcen in vorgesehenen
Territorien umgeleitet man geht also in
ein Gebiet übernimmt die Kontrolle über
die Kommunikation und nutzt diese
Kontrolle dann um Desinformationen zu
verbreiten soziale Medien zu
manipulieren und Informationen zu
unterdrücken
westliche Nachrichtendienste bestätigen
die Echtheit der vulkanpfeils erst
Firmen wie Vulkan würden russische
Geheimdienste zu Cyber-Attacken auf den
Westen befähigen doch wer sind Putins
cyberkrieger ein ranghunger früherer
Mitarbeiter lebt mittlerweile in Dublin
ein nachfrageversuch hallo können wir
ihn ein paar Fragen zur Vulkan Stellen
nein ich möchte keine Fragen beantworten
zu einer Firma Vulkan ich will dazu
keinen Kommentar abgeben
nur einer traut sich anonym vor die
Kamera er hat Vulkan mittlerweile
verlassen nicht ohne Grund
Russland ist ein Polizeistaat und ich
will helfen dass Regime zu schwächen die
Leute sollen wissen dass es Firmen gibt
wie Vulkan die diese Art von Software
entwickeln
weder die russische Regierung noch die
IT-Firma Vulkan haben auf detaillierte
Fragen des recherche-teams zu Putins
cyberkriegern geantwortet
wenn Sie wissen wollen wie die
monatelange Recherche zu den russischen
cyber-kriegsplängen ablief dann schauen
Sie sich die frontal-dokumentation die
ihr vulkanfiles an ab sofort in der ZDF
Mediathek
neben
Attacken und digitaler dissinformation
greift Russland aber auch gerne zu
klassischen Methoden etwa die Festnahme
westlicher Staatsbürger den dann
beispielsweise Drogenschmuggel
vorgeworfen wird wie der amerikanischen
basketballspielerinnen Britney griner
die dann von der US-Regierung gegen ein
russischen Waffenhändler frei getauscht
wurde Geisel diplomatie ist der unschöne
Begriff dafür nun gibt es erneut eine
Festnahme diesmal unter dem Vorwurf der
Spionage ein Klassiker festgenommen
wurde ein Korrespondent des Wall Street
Journals womit natürlich auch eine
Warnung kann alle westlichen
Journalisten geschickt wird immer
berichtet
es hatte was von schnell Gericht keine
ordentliche Anhörung für Evan
gerschkowitz der amerikanische Reporter
ein Spion allein die Behauptung reichte
schon das Verfahren für streng geheim zu
erklären und ihm seinen Anwalt zu
verweigern
ich durfte gar nicht rein ins Gericht
und die Staatsanwaltschaft sagte mir sie
hätten gar keine Unterlagen über diesen
Fall so was passiert hier immer wieder
nun verschwindet der 31-Jährige erstmal
wohin weiß niemand bis zum Prozess Ende
Mai und das Urteil scheint schon längst
gefällt auf höchster politischer Ebene
es geht nicht um Anschuldigungen so
gremmelsprecher pescov er wurde in
flagranti erwischt
gerschkowitz wurde in die katharinenburg
verhaftet 1800 km von Moskau entfernt
der russische Geheimdienst behauptet er
wollte die Rüstungsproduktion
ausspionieren im Auftrag der
US-Regierung das würde er nie tun meint
ein Freund des Wall Street German
Reporters
wenn Sie in den letzten fünf sechs
Jahren starke Texte über die russische
Gesellschaft und die Opposition gelesen
haben dann kam das mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit von Erwin das jetzt
ist schockierend und niemand glaubt dass
er wirklich spionieren würde
vielleicht revanchiert sich Moskau dafür
dass in Washington jetzt ein
spionaufflog der sich in
us-regierungskreise einschleichen sollte
unter falscher Identität als Brasilianer
Viktor Ferrera hatte der gebürtige Russe
Sergej chakasov an der Jones Hopkins
Universität studiert Kontakte in höchste
Sicherheitskreise geknüpft Teil einer
jahrelang vorbereiteten Operation des
russischen Geheimdienstes sitzt nun in
Brasilien in Haft soll Ivan gerschkowitz
etwa als Verhandlungsmasse dienen
wir müssen das in einer Reihe mit ihren
nuklear Drohungen und der Aufkündigung
von Verträgen sehen sie wollen den Druck
erhöhen und dem Westen signalisieren das
Moskau dafür jedes Werkzeug nutzt sogar
Geiselnahmen
es wäre nicht das erste Mal zuletzt
wurde Basketball Star Britney griner
zusammen mit einem anderen Amerikaner
frei getauscht weitere sind immer noch
in russischer Haft aber gaschkowitz ist
der erste US-Journalist seit 37 Jahren
dem Russland Spionage vorwirft
dieser Vorwurf ist lächerlich das stimmt
nicht und wir finden es unglaublich
lächerlich
moskau sieht das anders Evan
gerschkowitz drohen 20 Jahre Haft
vermutlich ohne rechtsstaatliches
Verfahren
jetzt noch mal weitere Meldungen des
Tages Seins
die Sonderregelung für telefonische
Krankschreibungen endet morgen sie war
in der corona-krise eingeführt worden um
Arztpraxen zu entlasten unnötige
Kontakte zu reduzieren und
corona-infektionen zu vermeiden die
Regelung wurde mehrfach verlängert und
zuletzt bis 31 März
die Gasspeicher in Deutschland kommen
relativ gut gefüllt aus dem Winter dank
eher
mildertemperaturen und Einsparungen
aktuell liegt der Stand bei gut 64% der
Präsident der Netzagentur müller sprach
von einem großen Erfolg und sagte das
wäre helfen die Speicher auch für den
nächsten Winter ohne russisches Gas zu
befüllen
der Anteil erneuerbarer Energien in der
EU soll deutlich steigen dass
EU-Parlament und die Mitgliedstaaten
haben sich darauf geeinigt die bisherige
Zielmarke bis 2030 von einem Anteil von
32 Prozent auf mindestens
42,5% anzuheben zuletzt lag der Anteil
EU-weit bei rund zweiundzwanzig Prozent
manche Altbauten und Willen des 19
Jahrhunderts so überaus prächtig
ausfielen gerade zu palastartig mit
Stokke und Gold und teils sind absurd
großen Ausmaßen das lag auch daran dass
das Bürgertum versuchte Glanz und
Lebensstil des Adels zu kopieren wer
reich geworden war im Zuge der
beginnenden Industrialisierung wollte
nun auch wohnen wie Fürsten und Könige
dabei aber ja keine Jahrhunderte alten
Schlösser erbte baute man sich seine
Paläste eben neu aber im alten Stil wie
die Familie Krupp ihre Villa Hügel die
ihr 150-jähriges Bestehen feiert dort
Färber berichtet
das hier steht als Einfamilienhaus im
Grundbuch der Stadt Essen die Villa
Hügel thront seit 150 Jahren über dem
Ruhrgebiet
drinnen 269 Räume mehr als 8000
Quadratmeter Wohnfläche die
Unternehmerfamilie Krupp zog einst hier
zu dritt ein
es war privates Wohnhaus Alfred Krupp
der Bauherr wollte hier mit seiner
Familie ein intimes bürgerliches Leben
führen dass die Dimensionen dafür
vielleicht nicht ideal sind das wird
jeder erfahren der hier in diesem Hause
steht auf der anderen Seite war das Haus
immer repräsentationsort hier soll die
Leistungskraft der Erfolg einer Firma
repräsentiert werden
Leistungskraft damals drei Jahre Bauzeit
trotz Lieferengpässen im
Deutsch-Französischen Krieg
Alfred Krupp verdiente mit seiner
guss-stall Fabrik sehr gut an diesem
Krieg Krupp der kanonenkönig der empfing
in seiner Villa Hügel dann Kaiser und
Könige als Kunden die bekamen
Gästezimmer mit vergoldeten Türklinken
hier wohnten nacheinander vier
Familiengenerationen bis zu 570
Angestellte sorgten für sie ihre vielen
Gäste und die Geschäfte auf dem Hügel
die Villa ist ein Spiegel deutscher
Geschichte vom Kaiserreich bis zur
Bundesrepublik mit allen hellen und mit
allen dunklen Facetten dieser Geschichte
denken Sie an der Nationalsozialismus
und ein Adolf Hitler der hier auch zu
Gast ist
Krupp und das Dritte Reich der letzte
Hauser der Villa Hügel wird in den
Nürnberger Kriegsverbrecherprozessen zu
einer langen Haftstrafe verurteilt in
die Villa zieht die alliierte
seit den 50er Jahren ist die Villa für
die Öffentlichkeit zugänglich jetzt im
Jubiläumsjahr gibt es Räume zu sehen die
normalerweise verschlossen bleiben etwa
die Küche
Originalrezepte gibt es gleich dazu
und noch etwas ist neu wir haben den
Hügeln digitalisiert wir haben ja
hügel-app gemacht mit der Menschen mit
ihren Handys durch die Räumlichkeiten
geführt werden und tatsächlich auch
Augmented Reality hinter die Kulissen
schauen können ohne hinter die Kulissen
gehen zu müssen
auch nach 150 Jahren geht die Villa mit
der Zeit und bietet Geschichte zum
Erleben jetzt mit App und Lichtkunst
das war zum heute schon mal gleich geht
es bei Maybrit Illner weiter die den
Verhandlungsmarathon der Ampel
aufarbeitet mit einer Gäste Runde in top
Besetzung mit allen drei
Parteivorsitzenden und um 0.30 gibt es
dann unsere heute schnell Update mit
Christopher Wehrmann und hier übernehmen
morgen Abend eine gerlindecke
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen geht der März zu Ende
er war etwas zu trüb deutlich zu warm
und viel zu nass deutschlandweit viel
mehr als 90 Liter pro Quadratmeter das
sind 60 Prozent mehr als im vierjährigen
klimatologischen Mittel zu erwarten
gewesen wäre wenn es jetzt noch fünf
Monate so weiterginge würde sich der
Grundwasserspiegel erholen jetzt kommt
erstmal ein Sturmtief heran Sturmtief
Markus bringt viel Wind vor allen Dingen
über dem Ärmelkanal aber auch über der
Mitte und dem Süden Deutschlands heute
Nacht ziehen erstmal Schauer und
Gewitter hier im Nordosten ab und in der
zweiten Nachthälfte setzt dann kräftige
Regen im Südwesten ein das wird eine
milde Nacht mit Tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 12 und 5 Grad und morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 11 und
16 Grad und vor allen Dingen in
Norddeutschland wird das morgen ein
total verregneter Freitag da werden sie
die Sonne kaum mal zu Gesicht bekommen
am Nachmittag kann es in Süddeutschland
häufiger mal für etwas Sonnenschein
reich da gibt es aber dann sehr kräftige
Schauer und Gewitter und diesen starken
bis stürmischen Wind wir erwarten 60 bis
90 Kilometer pro Stunde in Bönen im
Flachland und in den Bergen sogar mehr
als 100 Kilometer pro Stunde der Samstag
wird dann total verregnet sein am
Sonntag setzt sich von Norden schon
langsam die Sonne durch und am Montag
wird es so kalt dass ich Schneeflocken
unter den Regen im Erzgebirge und am
Alpenrand mischen und wenn sie für die
Karwoche noch ein Urlaubsziel suchen und
es wärmer mögen dann sollten sie
vielleicht eher Spanien oder Zypern
anpeilen bei uns bleibt es mit einem
hoch kalt guten Abend